en ces temps de crise de l'emploi reste
une priorité à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la communauté d'agglomération et ses
partenaires maintiennent leur effort
pour conserver une économie saine et
permettre à chacun d'y trouver sa place
explications tout de suite c'est bon le
traîneau est attaché à son frère on y va
et l'on début de cette émission avec la
cu majeur du mois la semaine de l'emploi
qui se tiendra du 15 au 23 février sur
l'agglomération et qui entre forum
rencontré information est toujours un
rendez vous incontournable de l'emploi à
saint quentin en yvelines
l'occasion pour nous de faire un état
des lieux de la situation sur le
territoire
le taux de chômage est plus faible à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qu'au niveau
national
on est un petit peu en dessous de 2 7%
alors qu'on est maintenant au dessus de
10% au niveau national ont néanmoins on
reste vigilant puisque le
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi atteint
près de 6700 personnes en catégorie à à
saint quentin en yvelines en
augmentation de près de 12% en une année
une situation qui touche essentiellement
les personnes les moins formés
c'est vrai qu'on a de plus en plus de
public qui privilégie le travail en
intérim
les solutions d'emploi immédiate au
détriment de la formation
professionnelle et de la construction
d'un parcours de formation de
qualification qui permettra d'avoir dans
un deuxième temps un emploi
un peu plus durable ces réponses de
court terme elles ont très vite leurs
limites et j'allais dire elles ont elles
trouvent d'autant plus leurs limites que
l'intérêt aujourd'hui est lui même en
difficulté en c'est un secteur qui est
en fort recul depuis un an avec une
diminution des offres d'emploi de près
de 20%
et donc ces publics là qu'ils ont fait
ces choix de court terme alors souvent
pour des raisons économiques un
également se trouve aujourd'hui en très
grandes difficultés sur le marché du
travail et dans ces conditions il est
plus que jamais nécessaire d'informer le
public sur les nombreux outils mis à sa
disposition par la communauté
d'agglomération et ses partenaires la
communauté d'agglomération depuis
plusieurs années déjà mais en place des
dispositifs tels que l'école de la
deuxième chance qu'elle soutient
activement qui a été créé
à son initiative voilà maintenant voilà
maintenant six ans avec une antenne une
antenne à trappes qui accueille plus
d'une centaine de jeunes parents on a la
mission locale évidemment qui est le
service public de l'emploi a dédié au
jeune public mais qui ne se fût pas
uniquement de l'emploi mais également
tous les problèmes périphériques à
l'emploi je pense notamment à toutes les
questions de mobilité de logement
le club face fondation agir contre
l'exclusion ou là ce sont les
entreprises du territoire qui
s'impliquent pour accompagner des jeunes
les adultes dans leur parcours de
formation ou de recherche d'emploi je
pense notamment au dispositif du
parrainage
on à la cité des métiers également qui
développe une offre de services
extrêmement large pour accéder à
l'information concernant l'orientation
professionnelle la formation
professionnelle ou l'accès à l'emploi
c'est un lieu où 74 partenaires
interviennent tout au long de la semaine
soit sous forme d'événement alors les
événements le film s'appelle ou métiers
atelier journée d'information vous les
partenaires de l'orientation de l'emploi
de la formation sont présents cela si
dès métiers soit il ya une réponse
immédiate parce qu'on reçoit les gens
tous les après midi et on peut répondre
à leurs questions soit on évite les
parts les personnes vers les partenaires
de la vie nouvelle
on a un accès libre la documentation en
accès libre tous filles et informatique
faire sa propre recherche d'information
d'orientation et de recherche d'emploi
et surtout d'assister à de nombreux
ateliers autour des métiers autour du
look autour de construire son réseau
comment mettre en valeur ses compétences
même si on a 45 ans
comment travailler sur soi et comment
mieux se présenter des partenaires et
des outils indispensables donc mais au
fait il ya tient encore des secteurs qui
recrutent plus on est qualifiés plus on
a de chance
j'allais dire d'accéder au marché du
travail attendons à des secteurs qui
recrutent pense notamment au secteur du
bâtiment travaux publics de l'hôtellerie
et restauration de la logistique
voici pour l'heure mais qu'en sera-t-il
dans les années à venir
or en termes d'emplois sur son compte en
ligne actuellement nous avons
plusieurs études en cours
avec l'état et la direccte sur la
gestion prévisionnelle des emplois
un diagnostic est en train d'être posés
qui devrait nous permettre de déterminer
les emplois futurs et aussi des emplois
en danger sur lesquels il faudra
travailler on a une étude sur l'économie
sociale et solidaire et puis une étude
sur l'allée l'économie résidentielle et
donc tout ça doit nous permettre de
créer une dynamique et de trouver
literie nos d'emplois créés dans les
années qui vont réfléchir sur l'emploi
et anticiper les emplois de demain c'est
aussi tenir compte du développement
économique
la meilleure manière d'essayer d'arriver
à faire évoluer la situation
positivement c'est d'arriver à avoir des
établissements des entreprises qui
proposent l'emploi la mobilisation pour
l'emploi qui est une mobilisation forte
nécessite d'être très très attentif à
saint quentin en yvelines au
développement économique et favoriser la
dynamique économique c'est continuer à
accueillir de nouvelles entreprises se
pense à des implantations en cours avec
par exemple mercedes benz dexter ou même
les entreprises déjà existantes qui
choisissent de s'étendre de se
développer par exemple le crédit
agricole est donc important d'avoir ces
implantations d'entreprises et il est
nécessaire aussi de soutenir et
d'accompagner l'ensemble des
établissements
même les plus petits à l'échelle de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est ce que
nous faisons avec la maison de
l'entreprise l'emploi il ya en irak
c'est d'abord le développement
économique
c'est pourquoi saint quentin lune a
toujours fait en sorte que
l'attractivité de notre territoire fasse
en sorte que les entreprises souhaitent
dont seulement s'installer y rester
secret à cinquante années c'est vraiment
notre priorité parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'emploi s'il ya pas de développement
des entreprises
l'autre côté on souhaite sur des
sujets aussi compliqués difficiles comme
le chômage des jeunes qu'on puisse avoir
des actions spécifiques en particulier
avec les cols de deuxième chance avec
les contrats d'insertion mais aussi en
suivant les mesures que prend le
gouvernement en particulier pour les
contrats d'avenir
de plus un autre problème non seulement
le chômage des jeunes mais aussi le
chômage des plus anciens et on pense que
le contrat générationnel qui est mis en
place par le gouvernement sera une bonne
chose et à saint-quentin mines on
accompagnera cette mesure est maintenant
nos actus du mois
et le début de ses actus avec une bonne
nouvelle qui prolonge notre dossier du
mois puisque avec plus de 6000 sièges
sociaux pour près de huit mille
établissements saint quentin en yvelines
continue de séduire les entreprises à
l'instar de mercedes-benz dont le pôle
d'excellence sur installé à montigny
d'ici la fin de l'année et l'on poursuit
ses actus avec un zoom sur les agents de
la propreté urbaine service cris par la
communauté d'agglomération pour
intervenir rapidement sur le territoire
à 5 il retire chaque jour de 30 à 120
kilos de détritus dans les bassins et
mène notamment 130 interventions
anti-tags parents et l'on termine ses
actus avec un rendez vous incontournable
pour les amateurs de courses nature le
sixième l'eco-trail paris ile de france
partira de la base de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
les 16 et 17 mars prochains et vous
pouvez encore vous inscrire pour cela
une seule adresse trail de paris points
comme un dossier que vous pouvez
retrouver ainsi qu'un article sur
papilles de déclic théâtre qui sort un
livre et un autre sur la slameuse miska
émis dans le petit quentin voix de
février alors à très bientôt